lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
ver cómo podemos aproximar límites
gráficamente y usando tablas en el
futuro también vamos a ser capaces de
aprender técnicas para resolver los
límites y para encontrar directamente lo
que es por ejemplo este límite el límite
cuando extiende a 2 de x cúbica menos 2
x cuadrada esto entre 3 x menos 6 pero
por ahora vamos a pensar en cómo
aproximar el límite entonces queremos
saber este límite de aquí y lo primero
que posiblemente quieran comprobar es
que es igual la expresión cuando x es
igual a 2 bueno si sustituimos me va a
quedar 2 elevado al cubo menos 2 por 2
al cuadrado está dividido entre 3 por 2
menos 6 y bueno el numerador me quedaría
8 menos dos por cuatro entonces es menos
8 por lo tanto toda la parte de arriba
va a ser igual a 0 y luego el
denominador es 6 6 y bien eso también es
cero y por lo tanto terminamos con la
forma indeterminada y bueno con esto
estamos viendo qué es
x cúbica menos 2 x entre 3 x 6 no está
definida para x igualados pero podemos
pensar a qué se aproxima la expresión
cuando x aproximados y primero vamos a
plantearlo visualmente así que si
tuviéramos que graficar lo y ojo estoy
tomando esta gráfica del sitio de smos
el cual tiene una buena calculadora
gráfica dora en ella pueden ver la curva
que iguala xq vícam menos 2x cuadrada
entre 3 x 6 y pueden ver que la función
está definida en todos lados excepto en
x igualados y es por eso que tenemos
este pequeño hoyo aquí este pequeño
agujero lo que nos dice es que la
función no está definida ahí y bueno lo
que quiero es aproximar cuando x se
acerca más y más y más a 2 de valores
menores a 2 o bien de valores mayores a
2 cuál es el valor de este límite al
aproximarse a x igualados ya este nivel
de suma parece que se está aproximando a
este valor de aquí así que cuando x se
acerca más y más a 2 parece que nuestra
función
se está acercando más y más a ese valor
de ahí independientemente en qué
dirección nos estamos aproximando y si
queremos saber el valor y lo calculamos
solamente con lo que tenemos aquí veamos
si este 0 estas 2 entonces por aquí
tendremos al 1 por aquí al 1.5 y a este
nivel de suma parece que nos estamos
aproximando a 1.3 o 1.4 muy bien ahora
qué te parece si le damos más sum y si
tienen acceso a una calculadora gráfica
dora o van a un sitio web como desmond o
wolfram alpha pueden hacer aún más sum
en esta gráfica así que nos invitó a
probar esto por su cuenta
o tal vez hagan otras gráficas para que
vean qué es lo que pasa si le damos aún
más um nos vamos a aproximar más así que
observa tenemos una nueva gráfica de
nuevo no estamos definidos en x
igualados pero aquí tenemos ligeramente
una mejor lectura veamos este por aquí
es el 1 por acá tenemos al 2 y el valor
al que nos estamos aproximando cuando x
se acerca más y más a 2
este valor que está por aquí y si veamos
qué valor tomáis james en ese punto
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 entonces justo aquí es
1.2 y x 1.4
así que parece que están entre 1.2 y 1.4
mil sería cómo 1.3 entonces
aproximadamente es 1.3 y algo así que
qué te parece si le damos aún más suma
para ver si tenemos una mejor
aproximación muy bien ahora tengo esta
gráfica de aquí y una vez más nos
estamos aproximando al mismo valor
observa que no estamos definidos en x
igualados pero cuando nos estamos
aproximando a x igual a 2
veamos estamos como por aquí aquí tengo
el 11.1 1.2 y 1.3 1.4 1.5 entonces
parece que está sobre el 1.3 y mucho más
abajo que el 1.4 así que es como 1.33 y
1.34 aproximadamente voy a decir que
1.33
parece que se está aproximando a un
entero con un tercio pero no sabemos con
seguridad recuerden cuando están
tratando de encontrar un límite de una
manera gráfica lo mejor que pueden hacer
es simplemente tener una buena
aproximación tratar de observar de cerca
lo más cercano que se pueda cuando x e
igual a 2 para tener la mejor
aproximación a un cierto valor como pasa
justo aquí ahora bien otra técnica que
tiende a ser un poco más precisa es
tratar de aproximar este mismo límite de
una manera numérica así que vamos a
hacerlo permíteme deshacerme de todas
estas gráficas ya tenemos una idea de en
qué nos ayudan las gráficas hasta
ahorita nos llevaron a este valor de
1.33 pero ahora vamos a tratar de
hacerlo numéricamente así que voy a
poner una tabla y te invito a que hagas
lo mismo conmigo entonces en esta
columna
voy a poner aquí a mi equis y en esta
otra columna voy a poner ayer que ya
sabemos que es igual a la expresión x
cúbica menos 2x cuadrada entre 3 x menos
y ya sabemos que cuando x es igual a 2
bueno esta función no está definida pero
veamos qué sucede cuando nos aproximamos
a 2 así que vamos a tomar valores
cercanos a todos pero más pequeños que 2
por ejemplo 1.9 o 1.99 también me gusta
hacer el 1.99 9 y también podremos ver
en la otra dirección podríamos tomar los
valores más grandes que dos y ver qué
sucede cuando tomamos el valor por
ejemplo de 2.001 y ver si ambos valores
se parecen y si es que se están
aproximando a algo y bueno también vamos
a ver qué es lo que pasa con el 2.1 así
que déjenme sacar mi calculadora y ver
si puedo evaluar esto muy bien si evalúo
primero 1.9 esto me va a quedar como 1.9
elevado al cubo menos 2 por 1.9 elevado
al cuadrado esto es igual a esta
cantidad de aquí y bueno tenemos que
dividir esto
entre 3 que multiplican a 1.9 menos 6 y
esto va a ser igual a amd
bueno parece que es aproximadamente en
1.203 así que solamente escribir eso es
aproximadamente 1.200 3 ahora vamos a
intentar con un 1.99 9 así que vamos de
nuevo tengo 1.99 9 esto elevado al cubo
menos 2 por 1.99 9 esto elevado al
cuadrado
me dan esto de aquí ese es mi numerador
y ahora mi denominador es 3 por 1.99 9
menos 6 y todo esto me dan 1.33 2 así
que esto es muy interesante esto va a
ser aproximadamente 1.33 2
y es que numéricamente parece que me
estoy aproximando de nuevo al mismo
valor que habíamos visto las gráficas de
cuerdas bien ahora vamos a hacerlo con
valores de x mayores que dos así que
permíteme traer mi calculadora de vuelta
am y te invito a terminar esto por tu
cuenta incluso pueden probar con 1 punto
99 9999 para que vean que realmente si
se está aproximando a ese valor ok vamos
a hacerlo con 2.1 entonces éstos serían
2.1 elevado al cubo menos 2 por 2.1
elevado al cuadrado menos 2 por 2.1
elevado al cuadrado es este de aquí mi
numerador y esto dividido entre 3 por
2.1 menos 6 este es mi denominador y
ahora obtengo 1.47 entonces es
aproximadamente 1 punto 47 así que ahora
pueden pensar que me estoy acercando aún
más a dos por valores mayores que 2
vamos a ver si nos acercamos un poco más
que podemos obtener
en lugar de 2.1 pongo 2.01 y de hecho a
ustedes les dejaré que hagan esto aún
más preciso pongan valores más más más
pequeños es más vamos a hacerlo con tres
ceros de hecho vamos a ser super
precisos no voy a tomar 2.000 1 elevado
al cubo menos 2 por 2.000 1 elevado al
cuadrado es esto de aquí es el mini
mediador y esto dividido entre 3 por
2.000 1 menos 6 y esto es igual a ok
esto me dan 1.33 35 redondeado observa
esto se está acercando más y más y más a
un entero con un tercio entonces diremos
que es aproximadamente 1.33 3 este es el
valor que en realidad tomamos cuando x
valen 2.000 1 así que observa
verdaderamente parece que nos estamos
aproximando a 1.33 3333 acerca del un
entero un tercio
pero una vez más ambas tanto la forma
gráfica como esta forma numérica son
aproximaciones si quieren encontrar el
valor exacto del límite hay otras
técnicas y vamos a explorar estas
técnicas en vídeos futuros